[Music]
[Applause]
alabama's the number one team the
preseason poll voted on by the coaches
and uh coach saban joining us on the
program what do you think of the
pre-season coaches poll
[Laughter]
funny you should ask
i don't think that
really it matters much where you start
the season
it's much more important where you
finish
i do think that
the team has to have enough maturity to
know that
it's great to get recognized
and respected as a team but this
particular team hasn't done really
anything yet
to
determine what its identity is going to
be and i think that's key to
sustaining over the long haul of the
season is to play with some kind of
level of consistency and
prove what kind of team you really can
have which
you know
it's nice to be recognized but it in
reality it means nothing
who did you vote for
uh i don't really
good question i don't i don't really
ever like to vote for us first i will
say that especially in the beginning
until we've sort of proven
who we are so uh i'll i'll leave it at
that
when's the last time you went into a
season and you went i got something
special
uh you know i think that
the 2019
team um
that had to deal with coveted
when we got knocked out of practice in
school on march 13th the first day of
spring practice and i said okay guys
here's what we're going to do
i'm going to give you an apple watch of
the scale you've got to go home and work
out on your own and we're going to have
three zooms every week
to go over the installs and what we
would have done in spring practice
over the air and nobody missed a meeting
nobody missed a workout
and this was all a choice and decision
that players had to make on their own
with
really very little supervision
and
the players really wanted to play that
season and
pretty special group to go 13-0 and win
a championship so
i i would say that's kind of the last
time
it's got to be tough you know all
coaches are control freaks and you don't
have that much control so you really are
relying on somebody 18 19 20 years of
age
to do what they're supposed to do
yeah but i think i'm been doing this
long enough to notice when you do have a
group that
shows that kind of responsibility and
accountability
that's something that you can really
work with and build on whether you're
controlling it or not
because there's a lot of things that
happen in the game that you don't have
any control of
so if the players control it instead of
you having to control you're a lot
better off
when's the last time you really laughed
smiled like something you know for
football that made you
i don't know cracked you up
like how often does that happen because
you're pretty good at keeping your
emotions close
well i think it happens a lot i just
think that sometimes people don't see it
i guess i'm pretty serious about what i
do
most people
who
have any kind of level of success
whether it's players coaches or whatever
or
you know they sort of enjoy the
the process of what you have to do to
actually um
you know have success so
i enjoy what i do maybe i don't laugh
about it a lot but when i'm away from it
i laugh quite a bit probably as much as
anybody
when's the last time you were truly
tempted to leave alabama
i've never been tempted to leave alabama
i think that
after
your journey we all have journeys in
life and you find out about yourself a
little bit more
in each choice and each decision that
you make along the way and
i found out when i went back to pro
football the last time 15 16 years ago
that that was my always my ultimate goal
to be a head coach in the national
football league and
you know once i got there i
said you know i enjoyed the college game
a lot because i love the
the development of players personally
academically athletically
a lot a lot of positive
self-gratification and all that
so when i got the opportunity to come to
alabama i was like
you know this is it for me so
i really not had a lot of temptation
to go anyplace else and i look at the
job here is
well it's a rebuilding year every year
you know you got a new team you got
new players new leadership
new people to count on
so you're really like
starting all over you don't need to go
someplace else and
try to rebuild something because you're
really rebuilding what you got every
year
talking to nick saban alabama head coach
how do you not make that meeting with
texas a m personal for
you it's not personal at all you know
the game is about the players um
and
you know my concern was not directed
toward any particular school i should
have never mentioned any particular
school it was really the state of
college football in terms of where we
are and how we're doing things and
what's happening
and i'm all for the players i'm all for
name image and likeness i don't think it
was the intention that
that whole scenario be used you know as
a recruiting tool for
anyone and um so it's really
my concern about the game and um but i'm
all for the players our players are
doing very well in name image and like
us we want to continue to support them
on that
when's the last time you thought about
retiring
i
i don't really think about retiring i
always think about what the heck am i
going to do if i do retire and uh
that's a scar that's a scary thought um
i don't think about it either coach when
people say how much longer are you going
to do this and i go
i i don't know why i i
i like doing what i'm doing i don't know
what i'm going to do if when i stop
doing it
that's exactly how i feel and um
i i don't know if that's hard for people
to understand there's nothing that i
want to do
like some people want to go to europe or
go to scotland and play golf and all
that i i don't
you know i wouldn't mind doing all that
stuff but i don't have to quit my job to
do it i worry about
you know what am i going to do if i
don't do this and when i say what am i
going to do i don't mean
play golf or whatever i mean how are you
going to get any kind of positive self
gratification feeling of accomplishment
when you've done something for so long
that you like so much and then all of a
sudden it's not there so
that's
a good question i don't really have the
answer to that one who retires first you
or bill belichick
that's a hypothetical question that i'm
not sure i'm
qualified to answer um
i don't know what his feelings are so i
really can't speak for him but
you know how i'm
i'm kind of committed to the grind
but could i see you coach a high school
team like uh
defensive a defensive coach for a high
school team like could you find
satisfaction gratification doing
something like that
uh good question
you know i like coaching players
when we have high school camps here
where we have young players
i enjoy coaching those players as much
as i enjoy coaching our players
of course you only have them for a day
or two but um
it's still the whole thought of helping
somebody get better that
i think is
you know coaching this teaching teaching
the ability to inspire learning so
if you're doing that i think
you know there's a there's a lot of
positive self-gratification in that as
well
can the sec get too big
numbers-wise coach
you know i'm not sure
i think we're probably headed in a
direction
like it or not
of mega conferences
how that all turns out and what's too
big and what's not big enough is
probably a
pretty good question to
try to figure out but i'm not sure
anybody has
the answer to that right now and maybe
we have
two or three mega conferences and
then you know that's where the playoff
teams come from i really i really don't
know but it looks like we're heading in
that direction yeah coach i wonder if
and i brought this up to greg sankey
that do you have like maybe 60 teams you
have afc nfc like you just use the nfl
model
well that's
that seems to be where we're heading um
is that good or bad
i'm not sure
it's probably going to be good for some
people
but it's not going to be good for all
people
because everybody won't be able to
compete at that level
so we'll create a separation
like at least probably 50 percent of the
schools
you know that are considered division
one schools right now would not be able
to compete
you know that way now maybe they come up
with some kind of way like
they do in soccer where
over in europe i think i don't
understand it completely where yeah the
relegation yeah where yeah yeah where if
you have a really good team at
you know wichita state
and
you you can qualify for the playoffs
even though you don't play
in that division
if i'm late
to one of your meetings let's say three
minutes late what happens
uh
we we don't um
you know first of all we don't want
anybody to be late
i think that punctuality is something
that players have to understand is
really important to help them being
successful
when we talk about everybody buying into
the principles and value of the
organization and
so that everybody is respected and can
gain the trust and
to do that everybody's got to do and be
responsible accountable to do their job
no different than
you know blocking the right guy playing
the right coverage going to the right
guy so being late is just a
an opportunity to learn a lesson that
you're not being accountable you're not
being responsible
and therefore how can you you'll be
trusted you know on the team so
this is a responsibility all
players people i think need to
you know understand and learn especially
when you're playing a team game because
you're not only responsible to yourself
you've got to be responsible to your
teammates as well i won't be late but
i'm just saying if i was did i do i get
yelled at or you know but i have to run
steps or something
you know
i don't think the
punitive part of it is
always helpful sometimes it's helpful to
some people
um i would say in your case it'd
probably defeat a lot of good but
i don't know that we need to do that to
everybody on our team
i like to run down steps coach not up up
step so just so you know if you punish
me let me run down steps okay
all right
uh good luck coach we'll check in with
you during the season always appreciate
your time
all right thanks man have a good day
all right
it's coach saban
you know he brought up a couple of
things he brought up relegation
now i kind of formed the question to
talk about afc nfc
you know nfl model fewer teams
and
he knows it's coming
and yes the sec can get too big but
that's where we're headed